[Music]
and just like that
and just like that the gang's all here
filming for the sex and the city revival
is officially in full swing for sarah
jessica parker
cynthia nixon and kristen davis and by
the looks of their latest stay on set
their kids are
all grown up
kristin who plays charlotte was spotted
walking with evan handler who plays
charlotte's husband harry
the pair were joined by two young women
who based on their matching ensembles
seem to be playing their now grown
daughters lillian rose
really this skirt is vintage
what skirt it's the creme valentino in
the snaps we see the three women
sporting coordinating white dresses with
colorful floral patterns
if you missed it during the series
finale charlotte and harry adopted a
girl from china
named lily hi hi
mommy's home during the 2007 feature
film the couple becomes pregnant and
welcomes a biological daughter rose
now we got a lily and a rose but not so
fast
they're not the only ones growing up in
the film
yep that red-headed young man seems to
be brady
miranda and steve's son
[Music]
who else is returning well remember
natasha
and there she was mrs big all
five foot ten of her yep bridget
moynihan who plays mr big's ex-wife was
also seen on set
fans will recall that she famously
played the second wife of mr big
whom he cheated on with sarah jessica
parker's character
carrie bradshaw carrie i see you
wait i knew you were having an affair
but not in my house
no i'm talking to you
after natasha discovered mr big's
infidelity she fell down a flight of
stairs and chipped a tooth
i would like to see where carrie and big
are right now i'm curious
and now so are we when we left them
after sex in the city two came out in
2010
big and kerry worked through a rough
spot in their marriage we know he's back
for the latest revival and according to
a leaked script online
they are now in the middle of a bitter
divorce and like it always will
time moved us on the highly anticipated
sex and the city revival
doesn't have a release date yet but we
can't wait to see what this next chapter
[Music]
holds
you